today's video is brought to you by
arpeggiato my online music school
specializing in all things that go pluck
you can sign up today for virtual
lessons with expert teachers for
instruments like classical utar
fingerstyle guitar ukulele and more
lastly you can meet me on zoom for one
of our online monthly events this
month's group class will be all about
adding musicality to your playing so
check out arpajata.com to learn more
hey friends over the years i've got
quite a few requests to do a video where
i show off my collection of plucked
instruments so here we go
[Music]
so my newest instrument is this really
beautiful bullback mandolin
which i'm guessing comes from about the
turn of the century so maybe somewhere
around
1900 but i've yet to do a lot of
research on it i really just got this
and my plan is to restore it to make it
playable because as of now
not quite playable um but i think i can
fix it up it's made by rudolph verlisser
and it's made in cincinnati ohio like i
said it has a bowl back
you can see the different ribs here the
bent pieces of wood just like on a loot
when you look closely you can really
see and feel all the wear and tear which
is just you know what happens over time
and actually to be honest i really think
all these little dings as long as they
don't affect the sound all these little
scratches and wear marks they just add
character to the instrument and they
show the life that this thing has lived
i really believe that uh instruments are
our tools you know and we should
we should play them
so the fact that this has been played a
lot and it shows isn't a bad thing i
think it's kind of a beautiful thing
actually
my other newest instrument is one that
i've had my sights set on for quite a
long time and finally have been able to
acquire one this is called an arch loot
and as you can see it is quite hard to
fit in frame
and that's because it's six feet tall
[Music]
this specific arch loot is a replica of
an instrument which was at the met
museum in new york
it was made in 1725 the original by
david techler
and you might be thinking wait a minute
this looks like a fiorbo and it's true
arch loots and theorbos look quite
similar the main difference is that the
arch loop has high notes
just like a renaissance loot it's tuned
in g
um whereas a theorbo
can't go this high the highest note on
the orbo
is that a b usually unfor the open
strings but this
the highest open string is quite higher
ig
the instrument has 14 pairs of strings
each pair
we call a course
we play them as one kind of like on a 12
string guitar or our mandolin one of the
coolest parts of the instrument has to
be the fact that the neck just kind of
keeps going it's like a giraffe guitar
and at the top we have another peg box
of
tuners of pegs up here and the reason
it's so long is that we can have deep
bass notes
[Music]
and the length is what allows that low
thump of this contour base a ranged
instrument that arch loop by the way was
made by michael schreiner in toronto
canada is a fantastic luthier the next
three instruments were all made by the
same company coming from turkey
salah music is a really great company
making all sorts of middle eastern
instruments and they've sent me three so
far and they're just so cool um i have
to admit though i really am not good at
them
and this one i have no clue how to play
yet so i thought i'd show you it because
it looks so beautiful
this
amazing looking instrument
is called a canon i hope i'm pronouncing
it correctly
the canon is a beautiful harp like
instrument that sits in your lap and you
pluck the strings the players who i've
heard so far play this thing are so
incredibly virtuosic and looking at it i
it's sort of sort of baffling to me how
you can make the music that i hear them
playing
we have all the series of
tuners the pegs in each corner just like
any traditional
autoharp or harp
and then there are three strings
per note obviously i haven't even tried
to tune this thing yet it's pretty
intimidating for me but the artwork is
beautiful the wood is gorgeous all the
sound holes kind of like my loots are
decorated rather than just being an open
hole they they took the opportunity to
make it beautiful which i i just love
that even the sides are
beautifully
decorated oh man
it also came with a little bag of
goodies
uh the tuner even is beautiful this is
to tune the pegs and then also
apparently to play this instrument the
way to do it is you
take this sort of little plectrum here
and you put that
inside of this little
aluminum
thing and then we have picks
on the end of our fingers to
pluck
again obviously i didn't tune in so it
doesn't sound beautiful yet but please
look up uh good kanoon players i'll
maybe i'll throw a link in the
description for you to check it out i
really have to meet a canoe player and
have them explain to me more about how
this instrument works
next up we have another instrument by
solid music this is the ood
it's an instrument that i'm really happy
to have
i'm not very good at it at all but
but when i play it it's so satisfying
and i realize how much
you know
nuance and beauty there is to be had
in the various music that can be played
on this instrument it's such a versatile
instrument and i've only cracked the
surface but i'd love to go deeper
through my research into the ood i
learned that there are lots of different
types of foods arabic goods syrian oods
turkish oods and more
this is a turkish ood food
it's quite beautiful lots of ribs on the
back just like the loot
bent backward
peg box which i love look of that of
course all
pegs like violin pegs again that's going
to be standard today
and then of course no frets
i love that
[Music]
it lets you get that wonderful sound
with all the micro tones
and of course this is an instrument
that's played with a
pick they call this arisha which i
believe translates to feather
and so this is an instrument that again
i really haven't spent much time on but
when i do pick it up and play it it's so
beautiful
[Music]
the next instrument i got from solo
music was this really cool electric ood
uh an instrument which i didn't even
know existed until recently uh it comes
with a fishman pickup fishman pickups
are always
really good
and then of course it's just like a
normal ood we have the pegs just like on
my arch loot in fact lutz apparently
descend from
oods or who like instruments um it is of
course fretless like always should be
uh and i have really not played this
thing much
it's gotta be tuned
um i have a lot of work to do to make my
owed playing sound acceptable
but i think i'm gonna have some fun
plugging this into an amp and seeing
what types of sounds i can get this
gorgeous instrument is called a baroque
loot it's made by a company in france
called lelout doje which means the
golden loot
and currently i have it strung as a 11
course instrument but actually it's
ready for 13
thanks to this really cool bass writer
here this extension
this allows me to have extra strings and
it adds a little bit of length uh which
makes the bass strings
sound a bit more rich and deep then of
course because we have 13 pairs of
strings we have quite a lot of pegs up
in the peg box here to deal with and
this can take me a while to tune in fact
i think the number one challenge of
today's video is the amount of time i'm
spending tuning each of these
instruments
but the really cool thing about the
baroque glute is the fact that it's
tuned to an
open d minor chord which is so so lovely
[Music]
and like all the other loots let's not
forget how beautiful
the back is with this really cool bent
backward pick box
now before we can get the baroque loot
we have to have the renaissance loot
right so smaller and less strings
uh this one is actually an eight course
loot i currently only have it strung as
a seven course though
and of course this is my go-to
instrument for all my elizabethan gigs
and renaissance music gigs
[Music]
now to some of my classical guitars i
have two guitars by sears they're a
company in singapore who make some
really reasonably priced instruments
this is their antonio torres copy and if
you know my youtube channel you might
know that i'm a huge fan of targa who
played tourist guitars and my 275
thousand dollar
guitar video playing capricho robbie
that was a
performance i did on an original 1888
torres which was sort of a magical
experience for me
[Music]
this replica is actually surprisingly
convincing and i really love to play it
another thing i love about this guitar
is that it has a shorter scale so the
the scale length is measured from the
saddle to the nut and that distance
usually on a standard classical tar is
about 65 centimeters um this one is only
64. and just that one centimeter uh less
kind of gives you a bit more of a
compact feel and actually i really like
it i love smaller guitars and even
guitars smaller than 64 are so
comfortable to play especially as you
get closer and closer to the to the
early 19th century guitars
[Music]
[Music]
now my other classical guitar by says is
an a90 c the c stands for cedar because
classical guitars often come in either
spruce top or cedar top and the wood
changes the character of the sound the
the timbre
so this is a darker guitar
and actually it's a pretty cool
instrument because the top has a lattice
bracing which is a way of bracing the
top piece of wood here in a way that
vibrates very freely supposedly and i
think i really can tell the difference
from the standard bracing now i actually
have this instrument strung as a
left-handed guitar right now just as
sort of an experiment on my own so
seeing if i could figure out how to play
lefty and i have to say it's super hard
but what's making it more difficult is i
have nails at the moment again and that
just doesn't work in the fretting hand
this one really it does have a lovely
dark tone and i recorded eric's tee's
nosian number one on it which i thought
sounded particularly good on this guitar
[Music]
this instrument by the way is one of two
today that are actually for sale right
now um i would love to keep all my
instruments
but practically i'm a professional
musician who needs the right tools for
the job and uh i need to make space for
some new instruments uh so uh this one's
for sale and then we'll catch up with
another one later on
[Music]
you